profundizar las relaciones entre Francia
y Arabia Saudita en citar los países
neutrales a condenar la invasión rusa de
Ucrania Esos son los objetivos del
presidente Emmanuel macron durante su
reunión de este viernes con el príncipe
heredero de Arabia Saudita mohamedman
París espera convencer a riat para que
intensifique su apoyo a quiebre y
utilice la influencia del reino entre
los países no alineados para presionar a
Vladimir Putin para que retire sus
tropas de Ucrania en marzo de 2022
Arabia Saudita y varios Países Árabes
entre ellos Egipto y los emiratos árabes
Unidos abandonaron su posición neutral y
votaron a favor de tres resoluciones de
la ONU que condenaban la invasión
también en la lista de alta prioridad
Irán tras seis años de relaciones
diplomáticas congeladas
realitieran reanudaron oficialmente sus
lazos el 10 de marzo con la firma de un
acuerdo en Beijing un alivio para los
países occidentales enfrentados a Irán
por su programa nuclear
Indicó que macron y mbs abordarían
también cuestiones de estabilidad
regional entre las que probablemente se
incluya la crisis del Líbano donde
Arabia Saudita goza de una gran
influencia y Francia espera sacar al
país de su estancamiento político sin
embargo Esta visita ha sido criticada
por el grupo de defensa de los Derechos
Humanos amnistía internacional
Esta es la Segunda visita a bombo y
platillo la última vez fue en julio de
2022 estamos conmocionados porque MVS
tiene una historial de Derechos Humanos
espantoso verdaderamente espantoso
Arabia Saudita es el tercer país con
mayor número de ejecuciones después de
China e Irán
Los lazos diplomáticos y los bolsillos
llenos de Arabia Saudita también serán
muy solicitados en la Cumbre del nuevo
pacto de financiación que se celebrará
la próxima semana y que según el Eliseo
pretende reunir la financiación privada
y pública allí donde más la necesitan
las personas y el planeta